The Star Wars prequel trilogy gave fans of
the popular sci-fi franchise many things:
a look at Anakin Skywalker growing up and
an explanation as to how he became a Sith
Lord; a peek behind the curtain at the politics
fueling the Empire; a huge pet peeve in the
form of Jar-Jar Binks; and even a young Boba
Fett, the notorious bounty hunter from the
original trilogy.
Boba Fett made his first appearance — chronologically
speaking, anyway — in Star Wars: Attack
of the Clones, the second installment in the
prequel trilogy.
He also appeared as a youngster on the animated
series Star Wars: The Clone Wars, which gave
us the story of how Boba Fett began on the
path to becoming the galaxy's fiercest, and
most fearsome, bounty hunter.
"You may take Captain Solo to Jabba the Hutt
after I have Skywalker."
"He's no good to me dead."
At the time of Attack of the Clones, the character
was only 10 years old and living on the planet
Kamino with his "father," bounty hunter Jango
Fett, of whom he was actually a clone.
Child actor Daniel Logan portrayed young Boba
Fett on the big screen, but what happened
to him?
What has the kid who played the most famous
bounty hunter in the Star Wars universe been
up to in the years since he came back down
to Earth?
For starters, the Star Wars prequels didn't
put Logan off from acting like they did with
young Anakin Skywalker actor Jake Lloyd.
Rest assured that the 32-year-old New Zealander
is still in the biz to this day.
After appearing in Attack of the Clones in
2002, Logan made a number of more low-key
appearances in films and on television.
In 2003, he lent his voice to the animated
series TakaPu: A Gannet In The South Seas
and the feature film The Legend of Johnny
Lingo.
He was even the voice behind the animated
incarnation of Boba Fett for five episodes
of The Clone Wars, which ran for five seasons
on Cartoon Network beginning in 2008.
A sixth was produced for Netflix, and a seventh
will be fielded next year on Disney+.
More recently, Logan has held roles in Sharknado
4: The 4th Awakens, playing a character named
— wait for it — Captain Fett.
He also appeared The Griddle House, and Underdogs
Rising.
He's set to appear in the theatrical feature
The Time War and the TV movie The Oath: Outbreak,
both of which are currently in post-production.
When the Star Wars sequel trilogy was announced,
there was also talk of a Boba Fett spin-off
film and at that time, photos surfaced of
Logan being kitted out in an adult Boba Fett
costume.
The actor is active on social media, with
plenty of photos on Instagram to show he still
has young Boba's cheeky side grin, and he's
also shared a number of images of himself
trying on a full costume or bits and pieces
thereof.
Of course, there's no doubt it was a costume
he commissioned for himself, as there's no
way a company like Disney would stand for
him sharing photos of an official costume
for a film before the studio had released
its own photos and trailers.
Nothing was ever confirmed with regards to
a possible role for Logan in the Boba Fett
film, but it certainly wouldn't have been
outside the realm of possibility for him to
make a return to the Star Wars universe.
It's quite clear that the actor would have
been more than happy to make a big comeback
in the franchise had the chance arisen; unfortunately,
the film was cancelled late in 2018, after
Solo: A Star Wars Story underperformed at
the box office.
Logan still makes as many public appearances
as he can with other Star Wars franchise stars.
He attends Comic Cons around the world, where
he poses for photos with fans and thanks them
for the continued support.
Although he certainly isn't among Hollywood's
A-list after the promising early start to
his career, Logan is still in the industry
and reliving his Boba days as often as he
can.
The actor is also married and has an adorable
little clone of his own, his young son Brad,
who might just follow in his father's footsteps.
Sound like someone else we know?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.